il s'agirait d'un nouveau vol avec
violence commandité par le
collectionneur d'art surnommée la grande
ombre
celui qui est en possession de ces deux
os et d'une certaine car tu peux
retrouver le reliquaire de la faune
en plus du fameux saints reliquaire la
légende parle d'un collier qui auraient
des pouvoirs de guérison je trouverai le
trésor de la fumée dit chen et vous
pourrez enfin être guéris ils nous ont
trouvés
et toi verrouillage non
la carte est dans la cathédrale de nida
route en route
[Applaudissements]
récupère la carte
on sait où et trésor maintenant
je crois que j'ai peur de tout perdre
[Musique]